after many years of making forbes
highest paid celebrity list
kim kardashian west is officially a
billionaire this year she made the
forbes billionaires list with a net
worth of 1 billion
kim kardashian west's name first
appeared in the pages of forbes in 2011
and at the time it was just a simple
italian for twitter followers
five years later she graced the cover of
forbes thanks to her booming mobile game
business
which helped her earn 51 million dollars
that year
the first time she appeared on a forbes
self-made women list
was in 2018 with a net worth of 350
million
five years after gracing the cover she's
officially joining the world's
billionaires list
the biggest assets in her empire are her
two lucrative businesses kkw beauty and
skims
kardashian west founded kkw beauty in
following the success of her half-sister
kylie jenner's kylie cosmetics
she borrowed from kylie's playbook using
a similar direct-to-consumer model that
relied heavily on social media marketing
her first launch which was 300 000
contour kits sold out within two hours
by 2018 just a year later her business
had expanded into eyeshadows concealers
lipsticks and fragrances
and was bringing in about 100 million
dollars in revenue
she cashed in on her ownership of kkw
beauty last year
when she sold 20 of the business to
beauty conglomerate cody for 200 million
dollars
in a deal that valued the company at 1
billion
forbes estimates that figure is a little
bloated and then her remaining 72
stake is worth about 500 million dollars
there's also skims the shapewear line
kardashian west launched in 2019.
she raised money from fashion industry
insiders like nedaporte's natalie massan
and theory's andrew
rosen and capitalized off of her massive
social media following
to show the brand the fast growing
company has been quick on its feet
during the pandemic consumers became
more interested in comfy clothes for the
couch
than smoothing their stomachs under
evening gowns and she swiftly started
turning the company's focus to
loungewear
it's mistaken skims that pushed her over
the threshold to become a billionaire
and what may cause her net worth to
continue to grow in the coming years
the rest of kardashian west's fortune
sits in cash and investments
including real estate every year since
2012 kardashian west has earned at least
10 million dollars pre-taxed by forbes
discount and some years it's much more
those paychecks come from keeping up
with the kardashians endorsement deals
and endeavors like her mobile game or
the now defunct emoji app
she's also got three properties in
calabasas and a portfolio of blue chip
investments including shares of disney
amazon netflix and adidas that her
soon-to-be ex-husband kanye west
gifted her for christmas in 2017. as she
tweeted herself the day she made the
cover of forbes
it's not bad for a girl with no talent
you